Let's go to our caller from the two zero one
area code who's calling today from 2 0 1.
It this needed.
Yes, it is.
Hi, I'm Syria and I'm from New Jersey and
16 years old.
I just want to ask about colvard 19.
What's going around?
Yeah.
So you cannot like about an hour ago that
the Democratic National Convention is to about
mid-August.
And now there's concerns growing over the
November election.
So what do you think is going to happen to
decriminalize like mail-in voting like Pelosi
suggested?
Or do you think the whole election will be
moot?
So moving the entire election is very complicated
because really what Trump can't move the election.
Trump can ask states to move it because we
have an electoral college system.
It's really 50 elections that we have.
So each of the 50 states would have to decide
to move it.
Now, the real problem is, even if you push
the election back from November 6th, I believe
it's December 14th.
There's some day around midnight.
Sorry, December 14th, right around mid-December,
where the electors have to vote.
So Massachusetts can vote later.
But on December 14th, the electors from Massachusetts
need to go to the nominating convention and
say Massachusetts elect or electoral votes
go to this candidate or that candidate.
That is very difficult to move.
And then beyond that, if you go past January
21, the speaker of the House becomes president.
So it's it's very complex to really move it.
Trump is resisting mail in ballots because
he knows that mail in ballots aren't good
for him.
More turnout, more people voting isn't good
And so I don't know what to expect, but I
would not anticipate that the presidential
election will be delayed.
I think anybody counting on that is likely
to be wrong.
You're just saying there's going to be some
precautions took, probably, but that's about
it.
I don't know if it's going to be it'll be
in-person voting with some kind of social
distancing measures, maybe more.
You know, the idea of more polling places
seems very difficult to imagine when you have
Republicans in power who want fewer voting
places.
Maybe vote by mail will be done in a number
of states, but not all.
I don't know.
But I think all of those things are more likely
than than postponed election.
OK.
Thank you for your input, David, I appreciate
it.
Appreciate it.
Great to hear from you, Syria.
From New Jersey.
Very, very good.